[Musique]
pierre lesquels un français installé ici
depuis son mariage avec linda noise nous
accueille
quand ça se prononce quelques cantons
les panneaux on va travailler ailleurs
ce soir hier
ouais frais
nous devons laisser les voitures
derrière nous elle ne vont pas plus loin
le message est clair ici nous sommes
arrivés dans un écoquartier et en effet
on découvre vite qu'il en possède la
panoplie complète
on se déplace à pied ou à vélo
les maisons sont bâties en bois isolé
pour la plupart en ouate de cellulose
leurs toits sont conçus pour mieux
récupérer l'eau de pluie
mais ce n'est pas seulement cela qui a
suffi à diminuer leurs émissions de gaz
à effet serre de 60 %
un record
pour arriver à un tel résultat ce petit
village danois a décidé de mettre le
plus possible d'équipement en commun
pour nous en rendre compte il faut
passer à table
ça se passe dans une maison comme les
autres sauf qu'aucune famille habite
vraiment c'est la maison commune de tous
les habitants du quartier et la première
chose qu'ils partagent ensemble c'est le
dîner plusieurs fois par semaine
à tour de rôle chacun se relaie pour
préparer un repas collectif avec tous
les voisins
donc ces trois là en train de préparer
un repas pour 30 personnes en personne
c'est par un soir de fête ce soir
ordinaire tafer oui trois fois par
semaine toute l'année et à peu près 30
35 personnes qui
ce soir là pour préparer la cuisine il y
à petter qui habite au numéro 40 de
jacob aux 64
et en que la femme de pierre
on mange quoi ce soir
cette fête une boule devient de façon
dans le four à la vapeur
dîner avec ses voisins presque tous les
soirs une idée inimaginable en france et
pourtant ces danois n'y voit que des
avantages
d'abord une économie pour le porte
monnaie car ce dîner aussi bon qu'en
restaurant coûte à peine 3 euros par
personne
ensuite et surtout c'est un vrai geste
écologique car pour préparer ce repas
collectif ces danois n'ont utilisé qu'un
seul four une seule gazinière et un seul
lave vaisselle au lieu d'en utiliser une
douzaine à la fois si chaque famille
avait dû faire la cuisine chez elle
partager des activités mettre en commun
des équipements voilà le nouveau mode de
vie qu'on choisisse et danois pour faire
du bien la planète et il partage
beaucoup plus que les repas pour
recevoir des amis par exemple est il
vraiment nécessaire d'avoir une chambre
qui ne sert que de temps en temps eux
ont choisi d'en aménager une dans cette
maison commune qu'il suffit de réserver
à l'occasion tout comme la laverie situé
juste à côté
pourquoi c'est particulièrement écolo on
mutualise en fait un espace que
normalement chacun devrait avoir dans sa
maison la cce m² qu'on économise dans
chaque maison chaque mètre carré coûte
en ressources et en énergie parce qu'on
n'a pas la construire parce qu'on a fait
à la chauffe et pascal éclairé donc on
écrit il grâce à ce principe de partage
les habitants ont ainsi économiser 900
m² de l'espace sur l'ensemble du village
l'équivalent de huit maisons de moins
construire mais cette politique
nécessite une certaine discipline plus
nordique que française
jane partagent les deux machines à laver
avec 30 autres familles du quartier ce
soir là pour nettoyer le linge de ses
trois enfants elle a dû réserver son
créneau à l'avance
suis venu pour réserver ma place avant
de partir au travail moi je voulais le
créneau de 18 heures mais il n'était pas
libre alors je me suis inscrite à 19
heures
vous n'êtes donc pas libre de choisir
quand vous souhaitez la vie aux
vêtements non mais ça m'a jamais dérangé
au danemark tout le monde respecte le
planning personne ne prend la place de
l'autre jane peut partir tranquille ces
vêtements seront lavés en son absence
le secret du fonctionnement de la
collectivité
c'est que chacun joue le jeu ici
et pour assurer la bonne marche de ce
village la plupart des habitants ont
accepté une tâche à faire soi-même par
exemple s'occupe des animaux de la ferme
qui fournissent du lait au village
[Musique]
certains entretiennent le potager
entièrement bio
pierre lui a pour mission de veiller au
bon fonctionnement du coeur du
dispositif
geoffrey ses deux cheminées la
la chaufferie c'est leur plus grande
réussite pour faire des économies
d'énergie tout en partageant les
dépenses
comme dans un immeuble ils ont installé
une énorme chaudières collectives qui
dessert chacun des 130 logements
individuels
elle chauffe de l'eau qui est ensuite
envoyée par tout un réseau de tuyaux
souterrains jusque dans les radiateurs
des habitants
et le choix d'une chaudière collective
c'est aussi un choix écologique
d'abord parce qu'elle fonctionne avec
des granulés composées de chutes de bois
un combustible entièrement renouvelable
et ensuite parce que son rendement est
bien plus élevé qu'une chaudière à moi
individuel
la chaleur
l' avantage de cet énorme four c'est que
la combustion du bois est bien meilleure
que dans un poêle à bois individuel et
pour nous le prouver pierre nous montre
les cendres qu'il reste après avoir
brûlé 7 tonnes de bois pour trois jours
de chauffage c'est ce qu'on a produit
c'était le fait que sa plastique il est
échangé ça fait trois jours c'est à peu
près 4 kg de sandres pour alimenter pour
chauffer 130 maisons c'est ce que
produit à peu près une maison un poêle à
bois traditionnels pour une maison quand
vous arrivez à faire aussi peu de sens
et cette efficacité énergétique d'aider
des grands systèmes
aujourd'hui ce système de partage
fonctionne à merveille pierre c'est
maintenant à quelles conditions cela
marche ici et cela pourrait peut-être
marcher demain chez nous tout est
affaire de mentalité des familles ont
commencé ici de projets le sujet
principal c'est que de toute façon on ne
peut même pas dire qu'on va dans le mur
on est déjà dans le mur quand on parle
justement environnement et la solution
elle viendra des citoyens des gens qui
comme nous se groupent essayer de faire
avancer les mentalités et puis aussi
d'expérimenter avec des systèmes
complets pour montrer que l'on peut
obtenir le même confort et même un plus
grand confort avec une mode de vie
durable
[Musique]